five years ago I thought I lost you
forever
there is no curse that could ever tell
me away from you will you marry me yes
[Music]
mistress I have a little bit of news
don't ruin my morning
congratulations on the film I'm so
obsessed with the Wardrobe and the
costumes are just so stunning so I need
to know what was it like putting them on
physically transforming into your
character and how did that ready you for
your performance well mine's kind of
easy I suddenly I have I become like
eight foot tall and I'm I have fangs and
horns so it's hard to be anything but
Maleficent yeah and you're in that
outfit know exactly what about for you
guys know it's such tight caught me I
think with these you know spike were for
Aurora for me it's like all right I
think about the iconic when they when
you look up the Sleeping Beauty you know
there's so many there's the ballet
there's paintings there's obviously the
Disney film it's like so I think we
wanted to pay homage to all of those
things and bring our best Aurora you
know live-action version that we could
so it's yeah it's really exciting I mean
she's of the woods and beautiful you
know flowers and the hair and then she
kind of she changes a bit when she
starts to live with Queen Ingres and
there's definitely a big shift and
that's also I guess me not to do yeah
her hair is up and so that's very not
her but it's an extension of the
character and the story so costumes
always helped me so much to because also
by the time I you know you're meeting
with the costume designer they have they
have spent sometimes a year really doing
research and so for me it's incredibly
helpful and and a big part of my process
and I think with Queen Ingrid the idea
was that she first of all wears her well
and just draped in her well with her
jewels and you know there's nothing
subtle about that and that she also
there's a sense of being in armor all
all of the time ready for battle
yeah oh my god costumes were so amazing
it's kind of like how I feel when I put
on a robe I like instantly feel rich for
some reason I like clothes can do that
question for you guys so in the movie
obviously Melissa
Maleficent sort of forbids Aurora for
marrying Prince Philip do you guys think
you should get parental approval before
getting married
no he really depends on the it depends
on the person the person's gonna do what
you're gonna get worst thing to do is to
say no because then they're gonna do and
they're gonna do it for sure yes I just
mean like should somebody get approval
and I think there's something lovely
about that tradition
yeah I mean I like the tradition of it
yeah I think at the end of the day it's
you want to marry who do you want to
marry right yeah yeah it's a tough
situation to be in if your parents don't
approve usually you're joining the MCU a
world that you're very much a part of
Michelle have you guys gotten around to
talk about yeah or exchanged words of
really well though okay we just got into
costume discussion costume association
yes no I mean I will be doing it's an
important part of the process the
costume I have a lot of questions
many who prey on the innocent I'm sure
your kind would agree if I didn't know
better I'd say you were making a threat
well do you do i what no better um
congratulations on the film guys I love
it so much because it's so much of an
origin story and we learned really where
Maleficent comes from so can you tell me
about your characters and who the Dark
Fae are yes so the Dark Fae you know
that they are as Angelina is as
Maleficent is you know a member of this
community this tribe that she has always
been separate from and now you know
finds that there are more of her and and
so she is part of a group and the Dark
Fae are in this conflict you know
they're in this struggle with with
humanity much in the same way that she
is and as she was in the first one you
know that there's there's this conflict
this difficulty with human beings and
that in some ways has has really defined
the psychology of the Dark Fae and how
kind of and they're sort of you know
they're together nurse their their sense
of self and they and the way that they
deal in sort of opposition with the the
troubles that they face in the world
that they live in is so stunning and
your costumes in wardrobe I was blown
away how did the physical transformation
into your characters ready you for your
performance like did you guys wear wings
on set no I think the wings for the only
thinks that were added afterwards
everything else was practical you know I
think you you kind of create these
characters you know we're analyzing and
working from the script long before we
put any makeup on forming ideas and
instincts and and approaches to how
we're going to do it and then when you
start layering on all of the physical
side of it and you've got these extra
cheekbones and pointy ears and you feel
the way of the horns and the hair on the
back of your neck and you know you have
these these claws and your fingers and
you know the kind of the way that
they're the
Costin would kind of make make you stand
with barefoot for the whole thing it
transforms you and takes you to another
level it informs you on a physical level
so you know all of the kind of
intellectual work that you've done
previous to that you then add on the
kind of physicality to that which gets
you a lot closer to perhaps where you
want to be and then we just go on step
set and just go on instinct and
autopilot and and it's very informative
and very helpful I know I can't imagine
was it costing you guys fly have you
seen the film yet yeah in fact something
I've never done before I don't know if
you've done I've never flied I've done
some on stage but not on film I don't
think yeah I enjoyed it it was great fun
it was good the machines for flying were
kind of there with that did you use
those sort of yeah in the tuning fork
thing and so you're sort of sent up into
the air and and you can also be moved
and there's always that thing where you
move but you know because if you're
flying your face kind of would probably
move before the rest of your body but
you got to coordinate that with
whoever's on the tuning floor cut the
mark you know because if they're moving
and then you know there's a whole lot of
you know I know choreography them I can
barely walk
correctly I don't know quick question so
in the movie Maleficent sort of forbids
and disapproves Aurora's marriage to
Prince Phillip do you guys think parents
should have approval before you get
married I think you know if those
parents can have opinions you know and I
think that opinions are valid and
informed on their own their children's
lives approval no no I think we are we
are individuals and that we should be
open to all all of the information from
our loved ones and close ones and our
mentors and Guardians as such but you
know the decision the decision is ours
I don't know I mean I think it's really
complicated actually and I think that
you know that I think I agree with you
you know that approval is one thing and
that's you know if it's like a kind of
you know very you know from the from the
top you know the people that know are
gonna tell you like an anything but I
feel like it's really important to also
kind of be open you know to be open to
everybody's to everybody's opinion I
mean it's almost what you're saying in a
way but I feel like it's it's very easy
to be very dismissive especially if it's
not what we want to hear you know but I
feel like there is a sort of balance to
strike between people it really depends
on where it's coming from you know and
really understanding that different
people have different opinions because
maybe their own experiences maybe there
is some sort of knowledge that is that
is that isn't work and as a play you
know I think we can sort of over ally
sometimes on the sense of our own
individual sense of being right and
being correct and and knowing things
that's what I'm off everything's about
that balance that this movie in the sort
of arcs that many of the characters go
on that we see changes in people's moral
codes that people are listening and open
to to different experiences and and and
and um open to changing you know in this
polarized time that we're in it doesn't
feel like everybody's open to that and I
think that's how we're going to you know
progressing and and and find the way as
it were by you know both listening to my
own instincts but also taking in
everything that everyone has to say ask
me to marry him
I wasn't really asking nor was I love
doesn't always end well beasty trust me
let us prove you wrong congratulations
on the film I absolutely love this film
so much I have a question for you guys
so in the film Maleficent sort of
forbids Aurora from marrying Prince
Philip do you guys think parents should
have approval before you get married
it helps no I asked my wife's father you
know just to be old-fashioned about it I
would have ignored him if he just said
no I think if I asked you in the film
you you would have given me an easier
time I would have done yeah but do you
Marcel is big softy really what about
you Harris do you think parents should
have her approval before I think it's
difficulties but two sides I think he's
probably important for the parents to
feel good about them but not ultimately
it's the individuals decision I agree so
what was it like for you stepping into a
role that was played by Brenton Thwaites
in the last movie did you call him did
you get any advice from him no do you
know I tried I think I just tried to
approach it as a new project and
otherwise it would be me it gets a
little complicated otherwise you know so
I just sort of looked at it from the
script and then jumped it from there
were there any sort of challenges though
just because someone else had played it
you know did you want to kind of well I
guess so I think I think the the film
had progressed quite a way in there and
Aurora and Philip was sort of at a more
mature level in their relationship you
know there were sort of adults entering
this this new way and they were trying
to figure out a new way to move forward
and lead both of their kingdoms and
unite them so it was mainly just
figuring that out yeah yeah Sam for you
you are the literal definition of a
wingman and I feel like your character
knows Maleficent the best can you tell
me what sort of does she have any new
powers or do her powers evolve in this
film um no I don't think I mean no she
does
have any more magic than she had before
but I think our relationship was
developed in the time you know any I'm
one of the only characters I know her
inside out and I know where her heart
really is and I'm the one who's sort of
dares offer
you know or try and you know direct her
in any way or offer advice and that's a
lot of fun I mean there was elements of
that in the first movie of the sort of
bickering married couple but I think in
the that's what we've all we've been
doing in the six years interim between
the two movies she can still turn me
into whatever she likes
right and we get to see you turn into
something else such as like um what
message do you guys want people to walk
away with after seeing this film I'd say
what came out for me and what would be
nice for people to take away is the sort
of the care for the planet that you live
on that certainly came through yeah yeah
I think the other thing is you know
there's a lot of it is it's about
celebrating our differences between one
another and not you know it's and not
listening to this divisive ideas that
the one type of person or one race of
person or one species in this sense is
is so different from the other that they
can't live live together I think there's
a lot of that in the world at the moment
and I think that's also another one of
the one of the messages here
[Music]
four-second Disney movie yeah did your
work on pirates of the caribbean dead
men tell no tales inspire any of your
work in this film well i think i mean
there anyway every movie is different to
make and
but at same time you get the bit more
experience you know for every move you
make and participles my first big you
know Hollywood studio movie and that was
daunting at the time and there's always
gonna be some level of that but yeah you
get a little bit you know knowledge of
how the machine works in a way and that
that's that's good to have when you're
when you're standing there with like all
these amazing actors and you know
thousand crew and yeah the Dark Fae the
world that they live in is so stunning
and amazing what was the inspiration
behind creating that world well I think
that we we wanted to create like their
nest of origin so to speak and and the
what we drew inspiration from was what
we call like different biomes in in you
know on the planet right now you know we
have the the the the tundra you have the
forest you have the jungle you have the
desert so I kind of wanted the the nest
to have all these layers as you came
that you flew deeper and deeper into it
and representing the the the four
different Dark Fae you know that's
existing in our universe it was so
beautiful and it's so cool because it is
an origin story and I didn't really
think we were gonna learn more about her
origin I would have thought you know we
would have got that in the last film so
what do you think people are gonna learn
that's new about Maleficent going into
this film well I think we will learn
that she's not the only one she's not
the only dark face she's not the only
Maleficent well we see her possess any
new powers turn into a dragon maybe yeah
what can I say that I don't want to
spoil it but ya know of course I mean
this is yeah I feel this is like
Maleficent taken to the next level you
know that's what I wanted to make also I
wanted to make the middle you know
Maleficent 2.0 version so so yes it's
the answer to that thank you so much so
in the movie Maleficent forbids Aurora
from marrying Prince Philip do you think
you should get parental approval before
getting married
uh well I'm kind of old school hi I
actually just got married myself six
weeks ago thank you and and I think it's
I think I kind of liked the idea of of
the guy asking parents or parent for for
the daughters or you know hand so in
that way that's what I did you know I
kind of like that little tradition that
said I mean Melissa she goes along with
it she tries to you know and that's what
I like about this universe is that the
motional you know core and the the
string between the roarin and maleficent
that i as a parent myself can relate to
you know
you